[Music]
five years ago I was sitting on the
couch in my mom's living room when a
Campbell's soup commercial caught my
attention Campbell's was releasing its
Star Wars branded soup and a commercial
began with a dad feeding his little son
which Star Wars shaped noodles in the
spoon same and I quote Cooper I am your
father the camera then zooms out so
Cooper's second parent is also seen who
then says emphatically no Cooper I am
your father my heart melts as I quickly
realize that without singing word
Campbell's was making a tremendous
statement by choosing to have two dads
in its commercial from that moment on I
knew that I company a company could sell
products while still taking a stand now
five years ago it had already been three
years since I first come out we're
coming out is always a continuous
process and I was slowly reconciling the
religious and traditional views of my
Caribbean household with my own sexual
orientation while we've made tremendous
strides in representing LGBT individuals
in the media today they're so few and
far between a common belief is that
brands should stay out of social issues
and many companies have chosen to stay
silent on issues going on today this
opinion is changing however and consumer
expectations are shifting instead in a
world where US consumers state that they
hold more trust in businesses than in
the government consumers are looking to
businesses to use their influence and
their power to make a difference in the
world and neutral is no longer neutral
it's choosing to stay silent in fact
according to Kohn communications 87% of
consumers say they were purchase a
product because the company supported an
issue that they cared about and 76% said
they were refused to purchase a product
if a company held use contrary to their
beliefs these statistics are evident in
brands that have gained support because
of their social values such as Evelyn
and brands that have lost support such
as chick-fil-a prior to my time at
Stanford GSB I spent my career in
marketing research and strategy digging
into the mindsets of diverse consumers
from all different age groups
demographics and backgrounds I've
interviewed hundreds of individuals and
one of the biggest learnings that I've
had is that individuals especially
younger consumers are expecting
businesses to be more personal and more
real to showcase this I'll share with
you an ad from the brand always show me
what it looks like to run like a girl
show me what it looks like to fight like
a dog
now throw like a girl so do you think
you just insulted your sister no I mean
yeah insulted girls but not my sister my
name is Dakota and I'm 10 years old show
me what it looks like to run like a girl
throw like a girl
fight like a girl
what does it mean to you when I say run
like a girl
you mean when fast as you can
this video has been viewed over 90
million times making it one of the most
watched ads of all time this is
incredible for an ad that doesn't even
showcase the product and following
launch up the ad always his Twitter
followers tripled in three months and in
a study conducted seventy percent of
women and sixty percent of men said that
the ad changed their perception of the
phrase like a girl in the end it wasn't
about the actual product it was about
what the always brand stood for since
then many other brands have followed
suit by choosing to join social
movements Starbucks for example promised
to hire ten thousand refugees following
president Trump's immigration ban in
2017 and following an incident in 2018
where two black men were arrested for
using a Starbucks bathroom the company
closed eight thousand retail locations
in order to hold racial bias training
for all of its employees and lastly
following Nikes very controversial colin
kaepernick ad Fast Company reported that
Nike gained a hundred and sixty three
million in earned media and gotten a 31
percent boost in sales the following
week in the end it wasn't about the
coffee or the shoes it was about what
these brands stood for and actions like
these will become even more relevant
especially as consumer demands in
corporate social responsibility coincide
with the fact that according to the US
Census Peru 50% of the US population
will be non-white by 2045 now I've often
gotten the question how do we know if a
brand is being authentic versus just
trying to make money I've pondered this
for a while with the conclusion that I
actually don't hear
whether a brand is doing this to sell
more products or to promote is social
values if they do it well then the end
result is still the same Nike will
promote racial justice in our country
always will further further the
conversation about gender equality and
Campbells will normalize LGBT
relationships and if they make money
even better when I sit back and I
reflect on the Campbell Soup commercial
today I think about the power of
representation it's nearly impossible to
fathom what you can become without
seeing others who have walked in your
shoes I personally remember the
Campbell's soup commercial so I can only
imagine that countless other queer
people that the commercial impacted
perhaps individuals who grew up in much
more conservative environments than I
was in or the power of the commercial on
straight individuals helping to further
normalize the fact that gay families
exists and are happy and are just like
there's moments like watching the
Campbell Soup commercial broadens
perspectives it brings a sense of
belonging and it can even change the
world
so as future business leaders I'm asking
that use your influence and your power
to promote change the actions you take
as overt as having an ad promoting
social issues where as subtle as just
having diverse people in your ads do
make a difference and can benefit both
your business and society and lastly
we're all consumers so I'm asking that
you dig internally to find the values
that are most important to you for me
its diversity or for you it could be
anything from workers rights to public
health to the environment then I ask
that you buy from companies that do well
in supporting those values and that you
stop buying from companies that
disappoint you then expect more expect
that brands show up at protests that
they pay employees for your wages and
that the people who work there or
as diverse as the people they serve the
movement is growing but the movement
depends on you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]